will captain pike's first officer be
sent to prison have we really seen the
last of chief engineer hammer and when
will james t kirk show up again these
are just some of the questions left
unanswered at the end of season 1 of
star trek strange new worlds
captain pike's toughest nails first
officer number one holds near legendary
status in star trek history previously
only seen in the original series episode
the menagerie which used clips from the
unaired original pilot episode fans have
always been fascinated by the character
strange new worlds finally reveals
number one's real name oona chin riley
and gives us her backstory as a
genetically modified illyrian in the
episode ghosts of illyria it's said that
because of the federation's ban on
genetic tampering people like number one
are barred from serving in starfleet as
such her illyrian heritage has been kept
a closely guarded secret when captain
pike learns her true nature he vows to
never reveal it because she is the
finest first officer in the fleet yet
somehow the information gets out in the
season finale pike's colleague and lover
captain battelle beams aboard the
enterprise with a security detail and
arrests number one for the crime of
being an illyrian we're curious about
what will happen now and who leaked the
information to starfleet the fact that
franchise cannon has never mentioned her
could suggest she spends the rest of her
days in prison either way it would seem
that number one's fate will be a major
story heading into season two
hard-nosed enterprise security chief
la'ann noonian singh's last name hints
at a frightening lineage in ghosts of
illyria we learned that one of her
ancestors is none other than ricardo
montalban's villainous khan but it was
leon's tragic backstory that added
pathos to the series in memento mori we
learned la'an was rescued as a child by
number one from a gorn breeding planet
after the gorn killed her family la'ann
uses her experience with the gorn to
defeat a swarm of gorn ships in the
episode then in all who wander she gets
a measure of revenge by killing three
gorn hatchlings and rescuing a young
girl perhaps reminded by her own ordeal
la'an takes a leave of absence to help
the child locate her family
but will she return
we know actor christina chong will be
back for season two but will we follow
her quest to reunite the girl with her
family or see her return to a different
starfleet chip chung has revealed to
cinema blend that she has filmed scenes
with james t kirk actor paul wesley
stating i can't speak on story but i can
say that paul wesley is very funny and i
love working with him the alternate
future pike glimpsed in the season
finale does show la'ann serving as a
commander aboard kirk ship this may
suggest la'an eventually finds a home on
the uss farragut the cast of star trek
strange new world season 1 combined old
favorites like captain pike and mr spock
with exciting new characters like chief
engineer lieutenant hemmer the series
most distinct alien officer and biggest
breakout character hemmer is an enar an
offshoot of the andorians who possesses
a form of precognition and telepathy by
the end of the first season however
hemmer sacrifices himself to save the
rest of his shipmates his death leaves
the ship without a chief engineer is it
possible that chief engineer montgomery
scott will make his debut next season or
are we due for another new character to
work miracles in the engine room
i like the ship
you know it's exciting
actor bruce horak who plays hammer has
said he's not done with the series in
several interviews whether this means
hemmer's telepathy allowed his
consciousness to survive like spock's in
star trek 3 or that he will somehow be
resurrected perhaps the next chief
engineer will still be hemmer
though fans were excited to see pike
spock and number one in strange new
worlds anticipation reached another
level when paramount announced that
james t kirk would be in season 2.
according to canon pike and kirk met
only briefly the strange new world's
season 1 finale snuck actor paul wesley
into the role for a what-if story that
took place in the future but kirk's role
for season 2 remains a mystery we know
kirk is currently a young lieutenant
serving aboard the uss farragut one
possibility is that season 2 may involve
dual stories set aboard the enterprise
and farrakit with kirk receiving a
recurring role based on the original
star trek we know kirk and spock knew
each other for years so it's likely
spock will get some serious screen time
with his future enterprise captain
however it shakes out wesley impressed
as kirk in his appearance in equality of
mercy unless paramount's announcement
was a ruse to hide the finale's plot we
should get plenty more of him next
season
since strange new worlds is set nearly a
decade before star trek the original
series it was definitely unexpected to
see actor celia rose gooding play cadet
nyota uhura on the bridge of the
enterprise throughout season 1 uhura
evolved from a fresh-faced cadet to a
strong capable officer in training
growing close to chief engineer hemmer
while rotating through every division on
the ship but uhura's dilemma persisted
does she really want to serve in
starfleet uhura makes it clear she may
not want to remain on the enterprise
unsure if this is the right path for her
but thanks to her friendship with
engineer hemmer and ultimately his
sacrifice it seems uhura may have
finally decided to stay however will she
be awarded a full rank of ensign an
acting ensign provisional title or could
she return to starfleet academy we do
know she'll be back on the enterprise by
the time kirk takes command but what
happens in the meantime is anyone's
guess
sanequa martin green's michael burnham
wasn't the first lost spock sibling to
be retconned into the franchise way back
in 1989 the fifth star trek feature film
introduced us to saibok the illegitimate
son of spock's father sarik he's a
vulcan who rejected logic and became a
fanatic devoted to finding god at the
center of the galaxy the film was met
with plenty of jeers and no subsequent
star trek series or film dared to
mention cyborg again
no
it's not possible
all that changed in strange new worlds
when the episode the serene squall
revealed seibok is being held in the
vulcan rehabilitation facility where
spock's betrothed to pring serves spock
notes that he has been told to avoid
contact with his half-brother at all
costs and the ominous reveal seems to
imply that the villainous vulcan may yet
return it has even been rumored among
fans that sybok could become the behind
the scenes villain of season 2. the fact
that the episode never shows his face
seems like a strange creative choice if
he wasn't set to return in some fashion
this way any actor could step into the
role and with sam wittwer campaigning
for the part on twitter another
appearance could be on the horizon
pulled from a pair of appearances on the
original star trek series strange new
worlds made minor character dr mbenga a
series regular and the enterprise's
chief medical officer expanding on the
little explored role we learn his first
name is joseph and that he has a
daughter named rukiya who is suffering
from a terminal disease mbenga's
relationship with his daughter provides
some of the most touching and heartfelt
moments in season 1. strangely in his
two appearances from the 1960s dr mbenga
actually serves under dr mccoy who is in
charge of sikbe when kirk commands the
enterprise what happens to umbanga to
bump him from the commanding doctor
aboard the flagship of the federation to
a supporting surgeon we know manga
risked the lives of the enterprise crew
in ghosts of illyria by not revealing
that his daughter was being held in the
transporter could this have been a
violation of regulations that gets
embanked demoted or is there another
incident lined up for a future episode
that sees mbenga either forcibly removed
from his role or voluntarily stepping
down with season 2 already filmed we may
not have to wait long to find out though
there's nothing to say that the change
in rank takes place anytime soon
in the 1990s star trek was one of the
first franchises that had multiple
projects side by side with both movies
and tv shows running together still
while a few characters moved back and
forth few proper crossovers actually
materialized with marvel dc and others
pushing interconnected franchises could
strange new worlds finally see a major
star trek crossover when asked about
future crossovers franchise overlord
alex kurtzman told deadline podcast i
think crossovers are can be really
really exciting
but they have to exist for a reason
strange new worlds seems perfectly set
up for such an event as it's set on the
franchise's most beloved starship and
has a cast of fan favorite classic
characters what could be more exciting
than sean luke picard traveling back to
the days of captain pike or ethan pex mr
spock traveling to a parallel universe
and meeting zachary quinto spock no
matter what form a crossover might take
there's no doubt it would be a major
event that would pull in massive
viewership figures and with paramount
and cbs now officially merged after
years of separation there's no longer
any legal reason it can't be done will
that happen during strange new worlds
season 2 we hope so
star trek the original series will be
just 6 years away when season 2 of
strange new worlds begins so the series
may begin to include more characters
we've seen before it already features
spock uhura nurse chapel and manga but
there's still room for plenty of old
favorites james t kirk is set to play a
regular role in the second season but we
don't know when he'll take over from
christopher pike likewise hikaru sulu
pavel chekhov and even yeoman rand could
have predicated kirk's time in the
captain's chair
scottie could be next in line to take
over engineering after the death of
lieutenant hemmer but is it also
possible that a younger dr mccoy could
join the sickbay staff on his way to
taking over for benga it's not just the
main cast members either the star trek
franchise is full of recurring roles
side characters and prominent one-offs
that fans would love to see again gary
mitchell elizabeth denner carol marcus
and matt decker could all make
appearances on strange new worlds
the most common adversary on the
original star trek and beyond the
ruthless war-loving klingons have long
plagued the federation but in the first
season of strange new worlds the
klingons barely get a mention
reintroduced in star trek discovery with
a controversial new look it's possible
that producers simply wanted to give the
klingons a breather or maybe they needed
some time to figure out what to do with
them after the divisive reaction among
fans by the time season 2 of strange new
worlds rolls around it will have been 4
years since we've seen a klingon in live
action and it may be time to bring them
out for a new adventure on the star trek
after show the ready room it's been
seriously implied that they could indeed
be coming back for the second season of
strange new worlds babs elusivemokin who
plays dr mbenga mentioned his character
has a bitter relationship with the
honor-bound alien race that will be
explored next year so perhaps we may see
them right out of the gate but the
question remains which klingons will we
see the ridged forehead klingons of
discovery or the bronze toned
smooth-headed klingons of the original
series if we had to wager money we might
even bet on seeing a new version of kang
core or koloth those three klingon
warriors who menaced kirk in the
original series
spock's betrothed to prang got a sizable
recurring role in season one of strange
new worlds in the original star trek
episode amok time we learn it was to
pring's resentment of spock's career in
starfleet that was partially to blame
for ending their betrothal we also
learned that while spock was serving on
the enterprise to print was involved
with a vulcan named stan who she wished
to marry in strange new worlds we
learned stan is a colleague of t'prings
at the ontashkin katil retreat a vulcan
criminal rehab colony on the third moon
of omicron lowry stan only gets a single
line of dialogue in this appearance but
it's still a major reveal that could
lead to a bigger role for stan in season
2. is it possible we could see the
beginnings of his relationship with to
pring which will cause her to reconsider
her commitment to spock with sybach
possibly being set up as a major villain
a trip back to on question katil and the
return of stan seems like it's in the
cards
if you're a longtime fan of the star
trek franchise you may have noticed a
pattern in the first season of star trek
strange new worlds where the series did
their own versions of classic episodes
there was the iconic prime directive
episode where the crew must decide
whether to reveal themselves to a
pre-warp society we also saw a disease
on the ship episode a fantasy come to
life episode and a monster on the ship
episode the season finale even did a
time travel story in classic star trek
fashion but there are still plenty of
classic stories strange new worlds
hasn't done yet perhaps in season 2
we'll see a crew member on trial episode
in fact with number one in custody of
starfleet security at the close of the
cliffhanger finale that one seems likely
we may also see the age-old omnipotent
being episode with the enterprise
encountering an all-powerful alien
life-form like q trelane or the
organians that toys with the crew while
these tropes and time-tested stories may
be cliched and a little formulaic
strange new worlds has found refreshing
ways of putting a modern spin on them
we're looking forward to seeing what
classic tropes they could trot out next
episode 8 of strange new worlds season 1
gave us perhaps our most puzzling and
unexpected easter egg in the elysian
kingdom we finally get a good look at
the storybook that dr mbenga has been
reading to his daughter and the author
is none other than benny russell first
appearing in a vision the bjorn prophets
gave captain benjamin cisco in the
acclaimed deep space nine episode far
beyond the stars russell was a fantasy
author from the 1950s who wrote stories
set in the star trek universe there has
always been a lingering suggestion that
perhaps there was more to cisco's vision
than being simply a dream but most fans
had brushed it aside as a mere fanciful
thought now with strange new worlds
declaring that benny russell was a real
author in universe we have more
questions was this just a throwaway gag
to amuse producers and set dressers or
does it suggest that cisco who lived
russell's life for a brief period
experienced something more profound
what if all of this
is the illusion
we're starting to wonder the same things
ourselves
by returning to an ensemble format
strange new worlds satisfied our wish to
see the franchise give the spotlight to
its wider cast the first season spent
time exploring captain pike number one
and mr spock's story arcs but there were
episodes centering on security chief
leon and dr mbenga while major b stories
were given to nurse chapel and chief
engineer hemmer in fact we arguably
learn more about uhura in the episode
children of the comet than we did in all
of star trek the original series sadly
one major cast member was absent from
the party lieutenant erica ortegas
captain pike's operations officer
ortegas is a navigator and weapons
officer and she was always active in any
scene where the ship saw action actor
melissa navia got some fun scenes when
off duty and offered a few cracking
one-liners but unfortunately she didn't
get an episode devoted to her could
season 2 see the series finally give the
spotlight to ortegas fans who love her
go get him attitude are certainly hoping
that's the case and so are we
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you